t'as pas les choquer la sécurité
français était entré à l'intérieur
oui mais vous savez bien que ça marche
pas comme ça et je le dis avec beaucoup
d'amitié parce que c'est je crois que
ç'a toujours été comme ça sous le
contrôle de notre consul général on va
pas d'échangé laisser monter la pression
il ya des règles les amis cette voie
qu'il faut passer de il faut que les
choses se passent aussi calme que ce pas
depuis ce matin on sait pas bien et je
suis pas en danger à l'intérieur donc
nous fait faire deux choses 30 la
provocation
alors voilà et je suis président de la
république française où l'axé
non
ok
et
m
des choses aller
allez
en seconde et l'autoroute nouveautés
n'ont aucun cas